♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoa!
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
That's --
You know what?
-I'm so confused.
-That's a lot of love.
-Yeah, that's so sweet.
I'm, like, genuinely
taken aback.
-Yeah, good.
-I don't know what to do now.
-I feel that way, too, though.
You've been on our show once,
but I feel like
I want to be friends with you.
I love you.
-Should we?
-Yeah.
-Done.
-You want to?
-Yeah.
Cool.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
You totally did it.
I know, I know.
How is "Saturday Night Live"
going?
-It's going really well,
actually.
Everyone is really cool.
It's very comfortable.
I feel like I'm still --
I forget that they've been
doing it for so long.
So, like,
things happen so quickly.
-Oh, yeah. -We were deciding
the sketches the other day,
and I remember
I was sitting in the chair
across from Lorne Michaels,
and everyone started
getting up and leaving.
And I looked at Lorne, and I was
like, "Oh, are we done?"
And he was like, "Yeah."
[ Laughter ]
-"Yeah, we moved on."
-I was sitting there
for maybe 30 seconds.
Like, it did not feel --
-There's no more scripts
to read. That's it.
-We go through things
so quickly.
-Is it because
you're savoring every moment?
-Maybe, I guess you could say.
But also, at the same time,
I'm so in awe
of everybody around me.
I'm also,
I guess, being really quiet.
I was looking at,
as we were taking the sketches,
he was like,
"Is there a sketch you prefer?
This one or this one?"
I said, "Oh, I think
that one's funnier,"
and he said, "Okay.
Well, then say something."
And I was like, "Oh!"
[ Laughter ]
-That's right. Exactly right.
-"Yeah, you're right."
-Obviously, you learned
some lessons
out of "Saturday Night Live."
-I think I'm learning.
I'm picking up on it now.
-Yeah, it's the best crew
up there, the best writers,
the best hair and makeup.
It's so much fun.
-Yeah, they're so seasoned.
-Yeah, it's great.
You're gonna be fantastic.
Break a leg this Saturday.
Come on.
We'll be watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We'll be watching
and supporting.
Last time we were here, we were
talking about "Wednesday."
And, man, oh, man, it turned out
one of the biggest shows
in the world on Netflix.
So, congratulations.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And since you've been here,
it got picked up for season two,
so there you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
More work.
Work breeds work.
Now you're gonna work more.
-Yeah.
No, I'm very excited.
-Do you have any idea
where you're gonna go
this season at all?
-I don't know.
I think we just started
getting a writers room together
and kind of talking about it.
And everyone's
being really cool.
I think we want to up kind of
the horror aspect of it
a little bit
and then get Wednesday
out of the romantic situation
and just let her be her own
individual
and fight her own crime.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You've been nominated
for every single award.
Congratulations.
Well-deserved.
-Thank you.
-Really. Can't get enough.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Do you like going to these award
shows and doing the whole thing?
-I don't think --
going to award shows,
the 30 minutes before,
it's the most sick
you'll ever feel
in your entire life.
You're so anxious, so nervous,
so whatever, and especially --
You're with people
that you admire.
Like, the SAG Awards, it was,
you know, all of your peers,
everyone who's a part of SAG,
so you're seeing
these people like --
-You had a hot table.
I loved your table.
-Yeah, I had
a really cool table.
-Yeah, Zendaya was there.
-Yeah, well, Zendaya,
I feel like we've kind of --
we've met and not met
so many times, I feel like,
this time, we were actually
able to have
a nice conversation.
But I was kind of freaking out
because she was sitting
next to Paul Mescal, who I think
is so talented and so good.
And I was so nervous
to meet him,
and I knew he was gonna
be at my table.
And I remember him --
he introduced himself to me
when I wasn't expecting it.
-Ooh.
-So he was like,
"Oh, hi! Nice to meet you.
I'm Paul."
And I was so nervous,
I kind of couldn't
look him in the eye,
so I fear that
it was a bit like --
-You were like, "Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah."
-"Yeah, 'Aftersun' was great."
-Oh, my God.
-You did that.
-I've done that before,
and you go, "Oh, my God.
That's so rude."
But you're just nervous,
and "You get me
at the wrong moment."
-I have that happen so many
times to me at award shows.
-But, no, the best thing,
I think,
was you and Aubrey Plaza
at the SAG Awards.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was so -- it was so funny,
and it destroyed.
It was a great bit.
And then the Internet
went on fire.
And it was, like, "We want
to see you guys in a movie.
Do anything together.
Do something. Play sisters."
-Yeah, I would do anything
with her.
She's another one of those
people where everyone
kept saying, "Oh, you remind me
of Aubrey,"
or, you know, "Oh, you two
should get together,"
and we just never did
until we were backstage then.
And she just looked at me and
said, "Hey, you! Get over here."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah!
See? Dude, she's so funny.
-Yeah, she was really cool.
-She's smart.
She's everything, yeah.
Can we talk about "Scream VI"?
-Yeah.
-It's a big deal.
Tomorrow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's out tomorrow.
"Scream VI" is set in New York.
Oh, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
New York City,
where we do our show.
How do we set up this "Scream"?
-Well, this time,
it's kind of --
Well, yeah, it's a different
setting, which I mean,
the "Scream" franchise
has never left Woodsboro,
so I think it makes for a lot
more an intimidating story,
I would say.
You know, Ghostface
can come for you on the subway,
push you off
a skyscraper building.
You know.
-Yeah.
-New York City
has got a lot of places.
-Everything about this --
[ Laughter ]
I think everything about this
movie is just bigger
and scarier, and also Ghostface
is just so much more brutal.
I feel like
he's very unforgiving,
and everyone's a victim,
not just the lead cast,
which makes it better.
-Now, do you know
when you get the script,
do you know who Ghostface is,
or do they change the script
so that you don't really know
who it is?
-Sometimes they give us
different scripts,
different endings.
This time around,
they just didn't give us
the third act at all.
[ Laughter ]
-So you gotta see the movie
to find out who the killer is?
-Yeah, now you just don't know.
-[ Laughs ]
-Everyone usually finds out
at least by the last two weeks.
-Yeah.
-But they try to play games.
-Congrats on that,
and congrats on "SNL."
You're gonna be fantastic.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Jenna Ortega
in "Scream VI."
Take a look at this.
-You and Tara
better watch your backs.
-You better watch yours.
-[ Gasps ]
-No!
-Unh!
[ Bike bell ring ]
-Come on!
Run!
Come on!
Help!
Please!
In there.
[ Door bell chimes ]
-Please!
Please help us!
Call 911!
-There's a [bleep] line here,
girls.
[ Door bell chimes ]
-He's trying to kill us.
I'm telling you, sir!
♪♪
-You got a problem here, guy?
-Ooh!
Jenna Ortega!
"Scream VI"
is in theaters tomorrow.
Watch her host
"Saturday Night Live"
this weekend with musical guest
The 1975.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.